what's your opinion on uh putin on the
way he threatened so in that situation
say it's 2013 and yankovic is sitting
there and he's kind of like uh i'm not
saying his name
is sitting there and he's saying
hey listen i'd love to do this and join
you but if i do our number one guy
that's doing business with us we're
going to lose 70 percent
in that moment when putin was bullying
yanukovych what was your opinion about
putin in that moment well my performance
had always been the same going before
that moment after that he's a thug what
you're seeing today
in ukraine was what those who were
paying attention to ukraine 20 years ago
saw
you saw the writing on the wall with
putin 120 years ago that you like did
you are you saying that you kind of
predicted what's happening today yeah i
i what i'm saying yes i mean
can i predict that uh
that the
rubble that's happened no i would never
have thought
that putin would have
leveled the country but did i was i
aware was or was anybody aware of
putin's desire for ukraine yes putin
always felt and again
in the in the west
things are right out there and you know
that we don't pay attention to because
we don't want them to be uh
true but putin has always said he
thought ukraine should never have been
given its independence by khrushchev and
khrushchev i mean the story on ukraine's
independence it was part of the soviet
union but it was an integral part of
greater russia khrushchev when he was
the general secretary in the 50s was
from ukraine he was ukrainian and so as
a gift on their independence day he gave
them their independence
never thinking that the soviet union was
going to collapse never thinking that it
made it was a distinction without a
difference
um and
you know putin was totally against that
i mean he wasn't involved back then but
he thought that was one of the two
biggest mistakes in the history of the
soviet union the other being gorbachev's
uh working with with reagan and uh and
bush to break up the soviet union so
he's always been an historical ukraine
is part of russia not ukraine is is an
independent country with russian
heritage have you ever met putin no
i don't know um
and
so so
what
putin was doing
with putting the squeeze on was because
he finally realized jedical which was
serious even though mind you
changing the legal structure changing
the economic structure changing the
regulatory structure it's a massive
amount of work and ukraine went through
that for the first three years of
yanukovych's presidency with great
detail working with the european union
uh they call it the the committee on
enlargement uh which is the body that
from the ec that deals with potential
new countries and i personally was
working with stephan rupalay who was the
commissioner of the of the commission of
the foreign enlargement and we worked
through
thousands of issues
uh all towards the end of getting the
trade agreement signed and then getting
the uh
the political it's called the
association agreement side
that was the key work during
yanukovych's time
where things went badly
for yanukovich with the west was about a
year and a half in
when he had his opponent former prime
minister timoshenko arrested
and he had her arrested for corruption
corruption which her president when she
was prime minister viktor shankar was
president victor yushenko accused
timoshenko of this same corruption but
it was part of his base so he couldn't
go after it later in life he did he was
very public about how she uh she
committed uh uh crimes and dealing with
ukrainian interests on russian gas
coming into the country but when
janakovich
you know
had her arrested the west went crazy uh
because she was the darling of albright
the darling of clinton
uh even though she was a corrupt prime
minister it was if you were for people
that don't know she would be the modern
aoc would you put her like that who how
would you say
her personality how she was
well i i know i wouldn't call it aoc i
mean
the the
uh she was a typical
soviet politician
uh but she was good-looking
she understood how to work the media
tyler
and uh and
she she sold herself to merkel and
albright and clinton
um
as the hope of the west the reality was
she was the putin candidate again in
2010. yanukovych which wasn't
again one of the the major misnomers
they didn't want yanukovych uh yeah they
and the reason they wanted her is
because
the corruption that she committed that
she was arrested for
was when she went to russia
to negotiate
the the agreement with the between
russia and
ukraine for the gas pipeline
what happens until the north stream
pipeline with germany all of the russian
gas to europe came through a pipeline
through ukraine it was very important to
ukraine's economic lifeblood
and uh this is her
uh yeah but it's her before she changed
her hairstyle so if you like this clip
and you want to watch another one click
right here and if you want to watch the
entire podcast click right here
[Music]